alors on passe à la deuxième partie de
cette chronique qui est en période de
fêtes de fin d'année ville la vigilance
a été renforcée auprès des commerçants
du territoire face aux risques accru de
cambriolage ou vol à l'étalage la
Chambre de Commerce et l'Industrie de
Versailles a même mis au point un
dispositif pour prévenir les commerçants
des actes de délinquance subis par
d'autres en temps réel grâce à un
système par SMS regardez ce reportage
vigilance accrue auprès des commerçants
des Yvelines en cette période de fêtes
de fin d'année le dispositif de sécurité
a été renforcé dans les zones
commerciales lundi la Chambre de
Commerce de Versailles a réuni force de
l'ordre et commerçant pour faire un
point ensemble
constate une stabilisation des faits en
tout cas de fait de cambriolage dans les
commerces en revanche on a une très
légère augmentation concernant l'effet
un petit peu plus violent c'est à dire
les attaques à main armées Carl Pitel a
été cambriolée il y a un an recettes et
bijoux lui ont été dérobés le choc passé
il a décidé de mieux équiper sa boutique
je vais essayer d'améliorer un peu
la sécurité bien que je l'ai déjà
amélioré quand je me suis fait
cambrioler mais là je vais essayer
d'améliorer au niveau du commerce la
police et la gendarmerie était présent
pour délivrer des conseils en premier
lieu le bon sens le pas mettre de la
marchandise onéreuse près des près des
issues de secours délester les caisses à
maximum et changer les horaires de
partage des convoyeurs de fond si
possible ou si on va soit même à la
banque ne pas hésiter à changer les
horaires ainsi que les parcours un tas
de conseils tels que ceux-ci déjà s'ils
étaient respectés à la base pourraient
supprimer bien des problèmes pour
renforcer le dispositif de sécurité la
Chambre de commerce va mettre en place
un système d'alerte par SMS les
commerçants pourront signaler chaque
incidence sur un portail Web sécurisé
les autres commerçants abonnés recevront
quelques minutes plus tard une alerte
SMS avec la description des faits
lancement de l'opération prévu début
cette sécurité ou cette insécurité des
commerçants on va en parler à présent
dans la chronique de l'Echo oui avec
Daniel Chalon bonsoir
vous êtes élus à la Chambre de commerce
et d'industrie de Versailles en charge
du commerce alors donc on le voyait dans
le sujet on va donner quelques chiffres
de la préfecture des Yvelines pour
compléter cela en 2012 80 000 faits de
délinquants sont été enregistrés dans
les Yvelines sur des locaux commerciaux
les cambriolages sont en légère baisse
en 588 cette année contre 597 en 2011
donc pas vraiment de panique pour
l'instant une diminution également des
vols à main armées sur des
établissements commerciaux moins 7% en
un an donc ces chiffres sont en
diminution mais est-ce qu'il y a quand
même une peur au niveau des commerçants
en cette période de fin d'année
nous cambrioler ont tout de même la peur
au ventre quoi qu'on fasse on se
souvient toujours de ce qu'on a subi et
ce qu'il faut aussi reconnaître c'est
que les commerçants qui ont subi ces
veulent ces cambriolages sont obligés de
payer les charges et puis la marchandise
renouveler c'est pour ça que la Chambre
de Commerce a fait et va faire on
s'appelle des cours de sécurité aux gens
ensuite le voir dans l'originalité
établissement ce qu'il en est aussi
l'établissement est vraiment plus ou
moins sécurisé de pas mettre une caisse
juste à l'entrée ou mettre des choses de
valeur à l'entrée donc une visibilité
pour décourager
l'adresseur on parlait de ses agressions
justement est-ce que ces agressions sont
aussi même si elles sont légères
diminution violentes de plus en plus
violentes
disons que si la personne qui est
agressée le commerçant reste calme il a
moins de risques d'être assommé et
adressé mais d'effort on a le réflexe de
vouloir sauver de façon bien sur l'outil
de son travail est-ce qu'il y a des
commerces qui sont plus touchés que
d'autres je pense notamment au débutant
de tabac oui aussi les bijoutier et tout
ce qui est les métiers qui génèrent de
l'argent il y a des métiers où dans les
bijoutiers c'est le marchandise qu'on
veut mais voler des espèces il y en a
pas puisque les gens payent par carte
bleue ou par chèque donc il faudrait
presque qu'on vienne tous à payer par un
moyen monétique et ça serait une
certaine sécurité pour les commerçants
vous parliez au de l'aide à porter par
la Chambre de Commerce et il y a aussi
une aide à portée par le service des
douanes qui concerne les débutants de
tabac c'est une aide spécifique pour que
soit financée soit un audit de sécurité
du local commercial soit une aide pour
acheter et installer du matériel de
sécurité donc si des débutants de tabac
nous regardent sachez que vous vous
pourrez bénéficier de 80% d'aide sur vos
achats pour un plafond de 10000 euros il
faut contacter donc les douanes du
département pour en savoir un petit peu
plus donc vous lisez la Chambre de
commerce ami en place un plan d'action
un portail web gratuit un abonnement au
portail sécurité on va en parler et puis
des prestations personnalisées en
fonction de chaque commerçant notamment
ses alertes SMS donc ils seront mises en
place au premier trimestre 2013 voilà
donc les associations de commerçants des
Yvelines qui font partie donc de la
Chambre de commerce offriront enfin
permettront à leurs concept alors laser
alors adhérent de signaler aussitôt par
SMS que dans telle rue dans telle ville
un couple que ce soit un couple un homme
blond ou une femme brune
donne des faux billets ou veulent aux
veulent dans les boutiques c'est-à-dire
que l'homme distrait le commerçant
pendant que la femme ou vice-versa
veulent donc ça sera des les réactions
directes ce qui vit en temps réel et ça
évitera j'espère
un maximum de vols
à Versailles
les commerçants de Versailles de
l'univers AC le font déjà ils envoient
des SMS ça fonctionne si vous voulez que
ça fonctionne plutôt bien je connais le
faire au département et ensuite à la
région ce sera un service
payant les SMS oui mais enfin comme la
Chambre de commerce je vais les acheter
en grosse quantité donc ça sera une
mutualisation et ça ne reviendra pas
vraiment ça sera vraiment pas cher
puisque le la Chambre de commerce le
vendra enfin façon de parler au prix
coûtant donc pour les commerçants c'est
intéressant et c'est une sécurité une
sécurité et il faudrait aussi que cette
sécurité joue aussi pour les commerces
non sédentaires que la police se promène
sur les marchés et sur les parkings ou
les véhicules sont volés
les commerçants non sédentaires leur
assurance ne rembourse pas la marche des
chevaux
bijoux n'importe quoi tout ce qui est
alimentaire est remboursé mais tout ce
qui n'est pas alimentaire n'est pas
remboursé donc le commerce on devra
rembourser
la marchandise acheter payer la TVA les
charges qui s'affairent à tout ceci et
ensuite malheureusement il aura la
trouille au corps en se demanda à chaque
fois s'il va attaquer ou autre chose
alors pour finir on va parler des
structures d'aide vers lesquelles
peuvent se tourner les commerçants par
les débutants de tabac il existe deux
autres structures tout d'abord le fissac
le fond d'investissement pour les
services l'artisanat et le commerce qui
propose une aide donc soumise à
condition bien évidemment mais si vous
êtes éligible elle peut prendre il peut
prendre en charge 40% du montant des
investissements pour la sécurisation du
magasin et puis également la CRAMIF la
caisse régionale d'assurance maladie
d'Île-de-France pareil soumise une aide
soumise à condition mais qui peut aller
jusqu'à 6000 euros par achat de caisse
sécurisées vous en parliez en début et
puis donc l'aide de spécifique aux
débutants dont on parlait tout à l'heure
Daniel Chalon est-ce que d'autres
réunions sont prévues sur ce thème pour
continuer à informer les commerçants on
le voyait dans le sujet un la
gendarmerie d'ailleurs qui édite
une petite information
voilà des fascicules à gendarmerie et
puis la police pour venir en fait ils
font du travail de terrain ils vont à la
rencontre des commerçants pour leur
donner des conseils est-ce que la
Chambre de commerce va aussi continuer à
alerter les commerçants
donc on espère faire plusieurs réunions
dans l'année avec les associations avec
les grands appellent les élus municipaux
et aussi bien la gendarmerie que le que
les forces de police automatiquement
c'est qu'un début et on est on espère
que les gens viendront en réunion pour
pour qu'on s'appelle pour comprendre
qu'on peut éviter tout ceci en
simplement des formes différentes peu de
choses et pouvoir travailler tranquille
soirée un petit peu en arrière sur
l'entretien qu'on a tout à l'heure au
tout début vous nous disiez les
commerçants ont la peur au ventre quand
ils ont été agressés par exemple on
entend assez souvent dans des faits
divers des des agressions de commerçants
qui tournent mal parce qu'ils se sont
armés aussi par exemple ça fait aussi
partie de vos missions de leur dire de
pas s'armer de d'avoir des bonnes
réactions et et justement c'est ça peut
quelquefois être plus dangereux pour eux
d'être armé que de ne pas l'être oui ça
fait partie de notre mission mais vous
avez les gens quoi que vous disiez c'est
leur bien ils ont travaillé jour et nuit
enfin jour une nuit enfin ils ont
travaillé pendant des années des années
pour pour avoir un comment s'appelle une
boutique agréable acheter des articles
qui payent et qui seront obligés de
payer 6 mois à l'avance ou trois mois à
l'avance
quand on vient chez vous et qu'on vous
veulent
généralement votre réaction et de réagir
ou alors si vous êtes assez intelligent
vous laissez faire et ensuite vous
subissez tous les
tous les symptômes qu'on peut avoir des
pressions peur
se demander quand on va attaquer la
prochaine fois les commerçants qui
abandonnent aussi justement quelques
fois quand ils ont été agressés du fait
qu'ils abandonnent du fait qu'on leur
vole leur bien leur marchandises et qui
n'ont pas prévu que cela peut arriver
dans une affaire va automatiquement mais
se retrouve à la rue non ils n'ont pas
d'aide puisque le chômage il faut
attendre six mois pour avoir du chômage
donc vous en avez beaucoup qui
qui sont dépressifs à 200% c'était de
prévenir de s'assurer suffisamment et de
suivre les conseils qui peuvent être
prodigués notamment par vous et des
conseils assez simples envoyés dans le
reportage ça peut être et puis vous le
disiez ne pas mettre en évidence la
marchandise onéreuse avec les
décorations de Noël ne pas masquer les
devantures par trop de décoration aussi
parce que du coup ce qui se passe dans
exactement voilà on peut moins
surveiller ce qui se passe à l'extérieur
moins de 3000 personnes qui habitent
dans la ville vous faites la demande
vous même sinon à partir de 3000
personnes vous êtes obligé de passer par
la mairie la mairie et la Chambre de
commerce est là pour vous aider on
rappelle le physique le fond
d'investissement pour les services
l'artisanat et le commerce merci Alice
merci beaucoup Merci à VOUS Alice on va
continuer avec l'info en plus de cette
chronique écho oui exactement alors elle
concerne les ex salariés de Nortel c'est
une première victoire pour pour ses ex
salariés on en avait parlé il y a
quelques mois la filiale française du
géant canadien des télécommunications
implantées à Châteaufort avait été mise
en liquidation judiciaire en
rappelez-vous environ 140 salariés
avaient alors contesté leur licenciement
ce lundi les prud'hommes de Versailles
ont déclaré le licenciement de 128
d'entre eux sans causes réelles et
sérieuse des dommages et intérêts ont
donc été prononcés pour 117 employés
allant de 21000 à 140 000 euros alors ce
n'est qu'un début pour les ex salariés
de Nortel ils veulent obtenir gain de
cause pour l'ensemble des employés
licenciés en 2009 467 emplois sur 700
avaient été supprimés on vous tiendra
bien sûr au courant de l'avancée de
cette épopée judiciaire c'était l'info
en plus de la chronique éco à présent
l'agenda comme toutes les semaines les
rendez-vous de la semaine à suivre en
économie oui alors on va le voir à
l'écran un deux dates proposées par la
Cité des Métiers de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui est basé à
Trappes tout d'abord un atelier CV et
lettre de motivation si vous êtes à la
recherche d'un emploi vous voulez vous
réorienter lundi 17 décembre de 14h à
16h c'est gratuit et ouvert à tous sur
inscription auprès de la Cité des
Métiers et puis un atelier sur le marché
caché atelier un petit peu plus original
animé par le Centre inter institution
des bilans de compétences des Yvelines
c'est mardi 18 décembre à 14h c'est
pareil gratuit et ouvert à tous sur
réservation merci Alice merci à vous
inviter également prochaine chronique de
l'Echo ce sera la semaine prochaine la
même heure chronique a retrouvé
également sur notre site Internet ne
l'oubliez pas vous pouvez retrouver
toutes nos archives et puis les
commentaires également ainsi que sur les
réseaux sociaux pour terminer cette
édition du 13 décembre le rappel des
titres la maison médicale à 10 ans à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux alors que la
ministre de la Santé vient de présenter
ses mesures pour lutter contre les
déserts médicaux les maisons médicales
sont montrées en exemple pour des emplir
notamment les urgences
l'apprentissage une formule qui
fonctionne les 42 CFA des Yvelines non
formés 16000 apprentis cette année un
plan national d'action va aussi voir le
jour pour renforcer ses résultats les
commerçants et leur sécurité une réunion
était organisée par la Chambre de
commerce son système d'alerter SMS
pourrait être mis en place les commerces
signaleront chaque incident sur un
portail Web sécurisé enfin l'opération
collecte de jouets proposé par skibus
comme chaque année depuis 1996 cette
fois quinze mille jouets ont pu être
redistribués à une dizaine
d'associations caritatives locales la
maison médicale de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux a donc 10 ans
elle permet d'assurer des gardes
aussitôt les cabinets fermés une
solution pour désengorger les urgences
reportages lors de la soirée
anniversaire qui se tenait il y a
quelques jours à Montigny donc
regroupez en un seul lieu des
professionnels de la santé capable de
prendre en charge les patients durant
les heures de fermeture des cabinets
médicaux de ville une idée portée au
début des années 2000 par l'Amicale des
médecins des trois villages de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux 2012 10 ans après
son ouverture la maison médicale de
garde veille sur 200 33000 habitants de
Saint-Cyr-l'École à Magny-les-Hameaux en
passant par Élancourt grâce à 40 mètres
100 généralistes volontaires
de pouvoir rendre service à nos patient
c'est-à-dire qu'on avait
une vision de ce que pouvait être la
permanence de soins à une certaine
époque il y a pas loin 10 12 ans ont
travaillé 36 heures d'affilée quoi je
veux dire aujourd'hui ça paraît
complètement fou mais c'est quand même
ce qui s'est passé et ça paraissait
normal tout le temps à l'occasion de la
soirée d'anniversaire de la maison
médicale Nicolas Abou ancien médecin
maire de la ville en fonction à l'époque
a rappelé ce qu'il l'a poussé à mettre à
disposition des locaux de sa commune
c'était un peu moderne parce que
on avait tendance à dire mais les
médecins ils ont qu'à se débrouiller non
la santé publique ça relève des
politiques et comme l'état n'assumait
plus totalement véritablement cette
dimension il était important que les
collectivités locales se prennent en
main pour répondre à ce problème de
garde qui devenait vraiment extrêmement
dangereux reste que cette réussite
suscite des convoitises la maison
médicale pourrait se voir imposer par
l'agence régionale de santé de couvrir
un territoire encore plus vaste les
médecins se disent inquiets les élus
partagent leurs craintes et si on
rajoute de nouveau patients je crois que
on va retomber dans les problèmes qui
sont générés aujourd'hui au niveau des
urgences hospitalières dont je n'ai pas
envie que ça se passe comme ça la maison
médicale est installée à proximité de la
police municipale les patients ne
peuvent y accéder qu'après un appel
auprès du 15
une autre information à vous donner
intouchable d'Olivier Nakache Eric
tolendano figure dans la catégorie
meilleur film en langue étrangère pour
les Golden Globes l'anti-chambres des
Oscars la liste vient d'être dévoilée
elle a cérémonie se tiendra le 13
janvier de bonne augure pour Omar Sy qui
vise toujours les Oscars pour ce rôle
dans ce long métrage aux marques vous
retrouverez sur tvfils 78 samedi et
dimanche à 12h et à 22h interview à
l'occasion de son retour dans les
Yvelines pour présenter de l'autre côté
du périph de David Charron et avec
également Laurent Lafitte eux aussi
seront d'ailleurs en interview lors de
cette édition spéciale le 7 8 revient
lundi en direct à 18h avec de nouveaux
invités je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée sur notre antenne et n'oubliez
pas l'édition du week-end le 7 8
week-end de présenté par Catherine
zulato dès demain vendredi bonne soirée